what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python with finance tutorial
video using quanto peon and zipline in
this tutorial we're gonna mean just kind
of building on the last one which is
where we were using the CSV fetcher to
fetch sentiment data on companies and
then we're trading based on that
sentiment data so here we found that we
actually did quite well we did 83.9% on
returns compared to the market's 52.6 so
that's pretty exciting but there are a
few things that we have to think about
first of all this is trading basically
october 2012 all the way late october
2012 till now the basically the regime
of the market so to speak has been up
alright the market hasn't done anything
but steadily increase and well that's
great and it's great that we saw that
hey we perform really well in a rising
market we haven't really seen how well
we perform in a sideways market besides
maybe like right here as the markets
going kind of sideways up and down i
can't really decide if it wants to
continue rising or not we're seeing at
least here we've lost some money now
that's not really indicative of what
we're gonna do in a true sideways market
but what we know is that we don't know
how this strategy will perform in a
downtrending market or even in a
sideways training market although the
market rarely will trend sideways for a
long time stocks like certain companies
might but the market it's pretty rare
for especially for strategy like this
obviously for you know over the course
of a week we might do nothing but this
strategy is more of a long-term kind of
thing so what we need to do is we need
to regardless of how it might affect our
returns it may it may actually increase
returns it may lower returns whatever we
need to short companies we have to have
that in there and this is just a good
time to talk about bias right so bias
right now we have to recognize that the
current market regime is just rise rise
rise rise but we need to have handling
for market regimes that are maybe fall
fall fall fall fall so that's what we're
going to be doing here and so to start
we're pretty happy anyways with our
Sharpe ratio and our drawdown kind of hi
it'd be nice to see that go down
I don't like a 12.8 we can basically see
it's probably right here or it occurred
and but the sharp is good we'd like to
see it above two beta
we'd like to lower beta quite a bit
especially for quanto pian but if we can
we would love to see beta lo on a
strategy like this where it really is a
heavy buy-and-hold kind of strategy
anyway let's go ahead and get started
and like before we've saw that shorting
allowed us to pretty significantly lower
beta so what we've got here is we've got
basically our trading logic so far and
what I'm gonna go ahead and do is add a
bit of logic right up at the top so this
is an initialize I'm just gonna add a
whoops context dot shorting equals true
and that's just for now but this is how
we can toggle shorting so right now
we're just gonna leave it true but as
time when it goes on you might decide to
use something that toggles whether or
not you're willing to short and
personally I think a great way to do
that is one of our previous strategies
where basically predicted market regimes
where we just had the MA crossovers
right
if the MA if the short ma crossed over
the long MA we were like hey this is a
rising market let's play and if it was
falling we're like no it's a falling
market let's short and that actually
proved to be a pretty successful
strategy at predicting regimes and we
actually did pretty well we had a low
beta and good returns we didn't meet the
market but we did predict the market
well enough okay so that could be a
starting point for predicting market
regimes and then applying either this
strategy or some other strategy that has
kind of two sides to it one that does
shorting and one that does longing so
anyway we've got that is done here with
shorting like a little toggle for now
we'll leave it there but you might have
something in the handle data that will
toggle it on or off so then what we're
gonna do is we'll come on down basically
to like right here you've got your
sentiment logic for investing so we can
even say begin long logic and then we'll
come on down here and then we can add
another thing that is like begin
shorting logic and then here we'll just
say if context short
so if contacts are shorting equals true
at the top that statement rings true and
we will run if it says false it won't
run so if contexts out shorting first
let's let's write some quick code here
we'll have a ma one and we'll have an MA
- like we did before let's make these in
pretty long ma so we'll say data for the
stock and that is going to equal or data
ma VG and this is a shorter one we'll
make this 100 moving average and then
for the second one paste move that extra
space we'll make that a 300 moving
average so keep in mind this is 4 per on
a per stock basis so instead of
predicting the entire market regime this
is basically the the regime for that
specific company but generally companies
if you look at companies especially the
companies that we're choosing which are
kind of big companies they're gonna
follow the market really closely so
anyways we've got moving average one
moving average to rates then we're gonna
ask the question if and then we're gonna
say if sentiment is less than or equal
to negative 3 ie if it's negative 3 so
won't have anything greater or less than
negative 3 right now and the current
position position equals 0 so we don't
have this company or we're not already
shorting it and whatever
so we're shorting I would expect the
current position to be a negative when
you short a company but that's not how
it works it is a positive number so even
though when you short a company you
really aren't having a position in that
company so I wish they would maybe tweak
that a little bit too so it was like a
negative but anyway and I might be wrong
but at least from my findings using
output to the log there is no negative
position even when you're shorting it's
it's called a positive so if sentiment
is less than or equal to 3 and the
current negative 3 and the current
position is equal to 0 then we're
interested but then we have to ask if ma
2 is greater than ma one so basically if
the short moving average is below the
the long one so that says hey the market
might
turning down so then we're gonna say if
cash is greater than the context
investment underscores sighs so if we
have the money to execute this kind of
short great we're gonna say order value
so we want to order a value of whatever
that stock is and then here we we do use
a negative and that's context investment
underscore size and as I'm writing this
I wonder if we can possibly reference
the value we're invested in a company
and that's how we might know whether or
not we were invest or like whether or
not we are actually shorting a company
I'm not really positive that that's good
enough but that would be kind of
interesting if that would work the other
thing that we want to do is because we
don't know what companies we know what
companies we have positions in but we
don't know what companies were shorting
or at least I don't know but now that
I'm writing and I wonder if maybe we
could reference it that way well we want
to have is another parameter that I'm
just gonna add up here at the top
there's context out shorting and I'm
gonna have a context shorts and that's
just gonna be a list and then coming
down here what we're gonna do is when we
actually short a company what we want to
do is we're gonna append it to our
little list so context shorts dot append
s so I append that company so now we can
always reference the shorts list to see
are we currently shorting that company
and again there might they're almost
certain I'd be really surprised if there
was no way to find out what companies
you're shorting on quanto peon I just
couldn't figure it out so I'm using my
own method for this it's kind of like
the cash thing I'm sure there's a way to
like track your cash per stock in the
handle data loop I'm just not seeing it
and I'd rather be safe than sorry so
might as well know for sure you're
tracking it so coming on down here
that's it for our you know to execute a
short but how about getting out of a
short because we need to get out of
short sometimes so to get out of a short
we basically we have to decide at what
point what logic basically would we want
out so we're gonna say L if
well if the sentiment is greater than or
equal to a negative one so at negative
three we short at negative two will hold
our short at negative 1 or higher we're
saying let's get out of this short so if
that's the case and then we're gonna
check to make sure we have the company
and or we have positions in the company
so if that's the case and our current
underscore position is greater than zero
because they use positive positions even
for short and s in context shorts so our
little list of short of companies that
were shorting if all of that is the case
then we're gonna go ahead and order
underscore target and we want to order
target that stock zero so we're saying
we want to have zero of that company now
you could quit here but the the next
most pythonic thing to do would be to do
context short start remove s so remove s
from that list you you really don't have
to I mean ok everything's satisfied in
this order target but you want to go
ahead and do that to be the most
pythonic thing so at this point I think
we're ready to rhumble we might have
errors or whatnot but let's go ahead and
let's run a fullback test check our
dates here run fullback test and we'll
see how this strategy does so so when we
move on from this just just talk about
something else for waiting for this to
load when we move on from this like this
strategy uses daily data so you have to
start considering how we might convert a
strategy once we're content with a
backtest to a strategy that can be
traded live so in order to try to
strategy live on quanto pian what you
have to do is you have to run a minute
back test and it doesn't really matter
what the outcome of that minute back
test is you just simply have to run a
minute back test so for this strategy
it's really set up to be a daily
strategy but what we could do is we
could put everything in
in a rebalance function right like we
had before rebalance it once a day and
that's all we do so we could do
something like that but because centex
is a like a paid api and stuff I just
wanted to show what the CSV fetcher can
do but I'm not too focused on keeping us
kind of stuck on using the sent text
data because not everyone is going to
want to trade sentiment analysis data
and not everybody is going to you know
want to pay for the API so so we'll
probably leave the syntax stuff behind
after this back test and so far it looks
like we're doing pretty well actually
I hope to see our beta come come down
it's slowly dropping so it'd be kind of
nice to see it drop uh-huh
any better alpha so far in a really
solid sharp so anyways in the next
tutorial what we'll be doing is we'll
probably start building back on that
long short strategy that we worked on so
that one immediately identifies market
regimes as far as like rising or falling
and then we can create a strategy that's
good in a rising market and I strategy
that's good in a falling market and go
from there basically so anyways that's
probably what we're going to be doing in
the coming videos but as far as this
video is concerned wow it's good good
so 101 think we were gonna do that much
better by shorting but when you allow
yourself to short a company then
basically you're allowing yourself to
make a lot more trades and that's
exactly what we've done apparently one
thing that's always good to do when
you're working with quant opium like I
was saying before when you trade a
strategy on quanto pian they're they're
just a it's just a platform for you to
do back tests so it's not their job but
to make sure your logic is sound in your
back tests so understand that and so
like I was saying before it's really
easy to like spend way more money than
you possibly have so at any given point
you want to check these bars and let's
say you're starting with a million
dollars if one of these bars is like 50
million you bought 50 million companies
and you go back to your code
like look because chances are you have
you've some sort of error there or
you're you're allowing yourself to take
on leverage because quanto peon is there
to let you do anything you want they're
just there to back test that logic
whatever the logic is you code so keep
that in mind so anyways this strategy
actually did pretty good we'd like
tripled from the market Wow
alpha 0.53 like to see it higher but
that's okay
beta 0.2 to look at us we can actually
compete in the the quanto peon contest
with that number
sharp 2.26 awesome Sortino information
ratio pretty low volatility ish but 18%
drawdown not happy with that but with a
156 percent return and that low of a
beta
I'd say we're cooking pretty good here
so personally I'll probably work a lot
on this strategy but for the purpose of
the tutorial we'll probably do something
else now we'll probably move off the sin
tax data if you want to work with the
sin tax data you can always contact me
and stuff like that and we can you know
work on something but anyway that's it
for this tutorial the other thing I will
just say is like okay say you've got a
return of 156 okay and you're just
you're having yourself a party you the
first thing you should do when you see a
return like this is first check those
transaction bars make sure everything
looks as it should also you want to go
to your currency daily positions and
gains that's pretty useful one but also
to go to I think it's transaction
details you can see like all every step
of the way everything your strategy
actually did so you want to come through
here check to make sure you know you
don't like all my positions are about
you know the same size like this one
we're selling a double position in
Gamestop but for the most part
everything's a hundred thousand okay so
and that was kind of our intended logic
was that we would only have a one you
know we'd have ten possible positions
and only in each you know company would
be a one tenth of our cash so about a
hundred thousand that's where we want to
be so like you go through here and
you're looking at that and you're like
okay that's great that's kind of what we
wanted
and then also go back to your algorithm
and really go through line by line and
make sure that the logic actually makes
sense okay because again in the back
test you it's just really easy to
produce leverage and you don't you don't
want to do that because then when you go
to trade it live you might not have that
lab leverage and then also leverage is
dangerous okay you might make a lot more
money but you might lose a lot if we
applied leverage to this script for
example we could apply to three or even
four actually we can apply five times
the leverage in theory possibly to the
script and our drawdown would be you
know eighteen times five possibly or
more or less depends but so you can
apply leverage and in theory this this
strategy would perform really well with
leverage but you have to be so careful
with this because again we're only
testing in a very specific rising market
we're only testing like luckily now we
have a shorting and given our other risk
metrics we're actually doing really well
so that's kind of why we use risk
metrics is because you know it kind of
can help us with overfitting but it's
not like a fail-safe against overfitting
so anyway that's a pretty exciting
return on the scripts so hopefully you
guys have been enjoying up to this point
that's a good one
couldn´t number to have but anyway
probably what we'll do is we'll move off
this and get started kind of making
maybe our own quanto being specific or
something like that strategy but anyways
if you guys have any questions or
comments up to this point please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions in its
hill next time